they kissed before we even dated so I
really could care less Scotty and toddy
my king you're our King oh my god first
of all thank you so much for having us
in your home this is like a cultural
epicenter of the vlog squad of course
David you know a lot bigger in person
it's scary
I take naps here sometimes to wake up oh
my yeah that must be a lot to wake up to
yeah honestly well that's it that's the
first time David and big I feel like
I've been in the same sentence but I got
this one well you guys have been so busy
you just got back from Australia with a
tour yo I mean well it's not like Scotty
I know you got to bring your mom to that
yeah that was sweet little Instagram it
was really cool bring him bring my mom
you know she had a moment where she was
like you know this is I think the
proudest I've ever been of you and so
that was really nice yeah it was cool
and getting to play some of the new
music over there right no yeah it's it's
awesome they know the lyrics to the new
songs already which is great because I
don't
[Music]
what's been the fan reaction to what's
going on so far have you gotten any
feedback I've gotten a lot of feedback
and a lot of people have their favorite
songs and it's cool that everyone is
choosing something different because it
means that each song brings a little
something different to the table you
know I try to make a cohesive album but
each song has a different message a
different sound and you know a different
topic but all with that cohesive you
know mental health sort of like
everything that I've struggled with and
put out into words in a song yeah and I
feel like the last time I got you guys
together
it was right before he going on the last
tour and there was you know Jeff had
just come into the picture everyone was
like oh Toby's replacing Scottie with
Jeff but now that that leg of the tour
is over that first one I guys how was
your bond I mean our bonds always been
strong Todd's got bran will never be
broken no Jeff can come between us no
girls nothing right yeah they've tried
they failed and now he's like forced to
hang out with me again we're forced to
hang out with each other because we're
gonna be on a bus for 45 days going to
32 different cities across the u.s. Wow
yeah or so he understands me and my my
different moods so it works out really
well yeah yeah like you like really
understands is this gonna be the most
amount of time that you guys are
spending events as a confined space
because at least in the house like
everyone kind of have their separate
rooms but now it's like we're gonna bus
so yeah you can't just storm off to your
bunk you know you can storm up to your
bunk but you're gonna be right movie
just walk up and do it like one of those
car scene drops oh yeah I think I'm
excited because I think I I mean I'm
excited to kind of you know take the
time in the bus really just sit down and
write and you know try to be creative
and like it's some stuff new stuff out
with Scott and make the guys in the band
so be cool we'll be living together
again clickbait we moved in together
yeah yeah that's a good quick baby you
can be now you are officially it's just
so happens
Oh first of all I can't please tell you
about this title and explain
yeah the meaning behind it I'll give you
a dollar if we consider this art yeah
it's kind of like a play icon like I
guess it's like art today like what
really is art you know people kind of
like push out stuff just to get stuff
out and might give use and make some
money but myself and my writing partner
slash one of my best friends Darren we
really like really aren't like it's not
like pretentious at all but we really
value like are just creating creative
process like we were we came over that
title like a couple years ago I guess
it's perfect it's what were like going
for the experts that you have a shared
on Instagram
already have been so personal start
sharing this stuff with everyone I am
very nervous to put this out in Jeff
yeah so like me writing I might just go
go go and put everything on there but
then when it comes to it like putting
this book out it's a very personal thing
and like I've said before it's like my
soul's in here yeah now people are gonna
read it and be able to judge and
critique my writing and our writing so
it's gonna be very interesting yeah like
personal stories um I guess
meaning like being vulnerable and a
bunch like there's stories like we're
like pretty on the nose to nonfiction
about like like finding love and like
being kind of like a hopeless romantic
and you know like being alone in life
and you know trying to find that person
to make you happy and then also not like
guided to like not depending on you know
someone else I can't let you guys go
before we do a round of blogspot gossip
because it's just Carly in there and I
just they really started to Tripoli
started at they created a monster where
we start blogs who I'd gossip there
couldn't be anything about me right I
worked really hard to get this - oh this
one scoffing so everyone from Kylie and
Kendall
to Paris alone we're on David's
disposable before you but you did
finally make it on the Instagram how did
that feel to finally get your pic on
there you know it was great but it was I
think the first one was with Corinna so
you know wasn't able to make it on there
on my own I had to have a heavy hitter
with me but it felt good to be on there
at all
finally so I mean literally everyone was
on there you were on there I got to be
around if I'm gonna be around and I've
been busy working on music and being
sick and broken so yeah well now Todd
you have about like seven for you Xena
is living with you yeah okay so what's
been like having Zayn as a roommate I
love it yeah examine Dynamat king or
break here it's been like a show in
itself
ya know it's they're both really clean
really respectful guys it's different
than other years ago I'll be honest it
like boosts my morale like when I wake
up yeah you know I don't know I don't
know what it is but I love like that
they're here it's just it's great like
we get along really nicely make each
other protein shakes the bus oh yeah I
truly do love it even though and David
Varga he was making out with right now
is that right at all or your attacks
Crawford no I know that no one's ever
gonna touch you
it wasn't really that awkward as what
you think yeah they've kissed before we
even dated so I really could care less
his bro code real in the Box part that
was like a real thing it was not just a
bit I'm sure you know dater after time
well you Olivia and Karina which I
thought was pretty cool it was just like
cool to see everyone just chill
ya know gear ya know be fit all
everyone's you know it's cool we're all
friends you know are without fading you
guys are just like everyone's cool so
are any of the bits awkward to watch no
cuz the one the latest with Karina where
she David said that she was macerating
Wow the truth did you masturbate at this
point it's just like just the bestest
you come in yeah I'm very thick-skinned
outside right it's like hard to care and
I feel like you for it everyone in the
group like everyone's just so good of
friends in general like yeah there's
been people that broken up and then
still remain friends in the group
yeah it's kind of just totally normal
thing yeah like Rin and I we're friends
you feel like now more than ever I was
like the group all you guys are just
killing it together but individually as
well so now that people are more and
more and more interested in yeah thank
your personalized does that make it a
little bit harder obviously not for you
Scott but it just it's interesting and
I'm like Ohio a people like really like
kind of grilling me on like some of my
decisions which I'm saying
guys don't have to like dig that far you
know I just maybe like enjoy us and give
us a like and like yeah people yeah
people have like definitely dug in
yeah really like I get some nasty DM
sometimes you know what it does make it
a little harder for me as well because
people are so interested in personal
lives and things that we have going on
in our lives and I don't seem to have
much you know crazy controversies going
on in my life okay they're not as
interesting no I just up here I gotta
think about them I gotta have a
brainstorming session like what can I do
[Laughter]
exactly I'm just really good at my life
that was an easy addition of Oxmoor
gossip I feel like right I mean yeah
nothing more juicy I mean what would you
could you what I know
honestly well I had
[Music]